South Carolina Governor Henry McMaster
joins us now from Columbia governor
McMaster good morning good morning
so governor we've been here talking a
lot about North Carolina today you can
update us on what's happening in South
Carolina well we're getting ready for
what's happened in North Carolina to
happen here Myrtle Beach of course is
right on our northern border there with
with North Carolina and we expecting the
the storm winds that is at least 30 39
miles an hour be there in any moment now
and we expect the hurricane winds to be
there by about noon and we expect the
eye of the hurricane to be in Myrtle
Beach at about 8 o'clock tonight and of
course the hurricane is wide it's about
300 miles wide the the hurricane winds
about 75 100 miles wide so it's coming
right across South Carolina and we
prepare and we've been evacuating we as
ready as we can be well 400,000 people
have evacuated one of the things we've
been reporting on all morning is in
Newbern people didn't leave and now
they're stuck what's your concern how
many people have not heeded those
evacuation warnings and are still in the
evacuation zone well as of yesterday
about 75% of Myrtle Beach had evacuated
we reverse the lanes on the main roads
so that the entire road could be used to
go away from the coast that work-like
like a charm we've got people out we
evacuated about two-thirds of the coast
issued an evacuation order several days
ago when people have heeded that we've
eliminated the toll on the coast roads
we have the National Guard the Highway
Patrol and everybody in between all over
the place Manning the roads and we've
gotten the people out very well that's
good have you had any reports of
injuries or fatalities no ma'am we have
had no reports of injuries and
fatalities we've had a lot of hurricanes
in South Carolina and our people are
learning more and more and they know
what to do and they're doing it but our
goal is to do the best we can with the
information and data that we're getting
from all over the world and not risk a
single life we're not gonna gamble with
a single life and so far it's working
very well seems like people are
listening to you what's being done for
the people who were who decided to stay
behind
well some decided to stay behind
we don't advise that at all but some
have decided to stay behind but once
once those storm winds get here once it
gets up to about 40 miles an hour
of course there it's very difficult to
go in and rescue someone so we've told
people if they decide to stay at some
point they could be on their own and we
might not be BAC able to get them until
the storm is gone because there'd be
electrical lines down all over the place
from all the rain and we're gonna have a
lot of flooding this would be more
flooding with this hurricane and storm
all over the state we think and we've
ever had before
so there'll be power lines down there'd
be trees down there be roads washed-out
and this could be difficult for the
rescuers to get back in yeah and you
have about sixty shelters throughout the
state that can hold about 31,000 people
right now about 4,000 have already moved
into those shelters for those who want
to move into additional shelters how
should they find out where should they
seek information they should stay there
the numbers have been broadcast in
publish they should go to they can call
9-1-1 they can go to the local emergency
management calls that those numbers and
all that information has been broadcast
all over the place but we have about I
think 76 shelters that operate now at
over 6,000 people and we're telling
people if you bring your pets don't
leave your pets and animals at home
bring yourself and your animals and you
will not be turned away from any of
these shelters and we have about our
31,000 capacity that we haven't even
excuse me we have a but we have a great
capacity we've got about 35,000 already
and some more after that and we can
annex if we need them we're ready for
this storm we just want the people to to
get out and don't try to go back in
until we tell them is safe we're not
messing around if this storm is coming
your way thank you so much for joining
us we appreciate it